al menos 3000 migrantes esperan
impacientes en la pequeña ciudad
nigeriana de asamaca provienen de
decenas de países del África
subsahariana e intentan cruzar El Sahara
para llegar a Argelia y luego a Europa
fueron detenidos en Argelia y después
expulsados a níger algunos llevan más de
dos meses atrapados aquí
cientos de estas personas llegan heridas
a níger acusan a la policía argelina de
recurrir a la violencia
estábamos corriendo nos golpearon y nos
caímos
Ellos nos hicieron esto mi amigo y yo
tuvimos fracturas en los pies lo ven La
mayoría están registrados en un centro
de tránsito con capacidad para mil
personas Pero al menos dos mil más
solicitan ayuda a la organización
internacional para las migraciones en
las hamaca la raíz del problema no es
solo la ralentización de la
repatriaciones debido a la crisis del
covid-19 sino también las expulsiones
regulares por parte de las autoridades
angelinas en condiciones muy difíciles
nos tiraron al Desierto a las 4 de la
mañana
Sin comida sin agua yo ni siquiera tenía
fuerzas daban vueltas alrededor de
nosotros con su vehículo
disparaban para hacernos subir
después de esta filmación nos pusimos en
contacto con la embajada de la cual no
nos quiso conceder una entrevista
a pocos kilómetros cerca de la frontera
se encuentra
duna un lugar donde antiguamente solo se
aprovisionaban los transportistas los
pocos comerciantes que trabajan aquí
son testigos de la llegada de grupos de
personas expulsadas de Argelia
han sufrido algunos no tienen zapatos
otros llegan sin ropa cuando llegan aquí
ya han sufrido mucho
la cantidad de gente que llega aquí ha
aumentado Antes había cinco tiendas
ahora Lo pueden ver con sus propios ojos
cada año aumenta el número de personas
las organizaciones humanitarias llevan a
cabo operaciones de rescate en El Sahara
para evitar que los migrantes perdidos
en el desierto mueran por deshidratación
Ibrahim françois va al rescate de los
más vulnerables en su motocarro
en el último convoy hubo uno que saltó
del vehículo se cayó
le salía sangre por los oídos y por la
boca
al final falleció fue enterrado aquí en
asamaca
cuando llegan se les entrega este
librito para que conozcan los peligros
que hay por el camino
al menos 30 personas que fueron
abandonadas en el desierto por las
autoridades argentinas han perdido la
vida en el norte de asamaca desde el
en el norte del país los centros de
tránsito de la organización
internacional para las migraciones están
al límite de su capacidad una de las
soluciones para descongestionarlos es
que los migrantes regresen
voluntariamente a su país de origen pero
gran parte de los procedimientos están
paralizados nos encontramos con una
sobrepoblación de beneficiarios Se
podría decir que generalmente nos faltan
recursos tanto económicos como de
personal para asistir a esta gran
cantidad de personas
en el centro de tránsito de asamaca
sobre poblado desde hace meses varios
organismos humanitarios temen la
propagación de enfermedades
nunca se sabe cuándo puede producirse
una epidemia cuando algunas enfermedades
estallan incluso cuando solo se contagia
una persona es preocupante
Ellos están muy cerca los unos de los
otros son muchos viven juntos Esa es
nuestra preocupación
desde principios de 2022 el número de
refugiados en suelo nigeriano aumentado
casi un 20% hasta el 30 de octubre estas
cifras ascendía casi 400.000 personas
las crisis de seguridad en Mali burkina
faso y Nigeria siguen empujando a miles
de personas a oír hacia níger
[Música]